les cloches de la basilique notre dame
de montréal ont retenti ce sourire
de nombreux fidèles se sont rassemblées
pour une messe spéciale ayant en tête la
douleur du peuple français
le ravage de notre dame de paris
rappelle que la basilique montréalaise a
elle aussi été la proie des flammes ce
vers 6h45 que les flammes se sont
attaquées à cet édifice en 1978 un feu a
ravagé une partie du bâtiment sa
reconstruction a permis de mieux le
protéger contre de futures incendie on
modifie la protection incendie en
installant un panneau de leur protection
incendie on ne l'interdît gicleurs plus
cher car le système 5 humides ainsi qu'à
l'extérieur donc le bâtiment même
protégé dans son enveloppe à la
cathédrale marie-reine-du-monde un
système de gicleurs a été installée en
l'an 2000 l'oratoire saint joseph a
aussi été mise aux normes
il conduit gittler est un système
d'alarmé ces matériaux le protège aussi
contrairement notre-dame de paris
nous ici à là à toi notre structure elle
est composée de béton et d'acier
principalement alors ce sont des
matériaux qu'on appelle un combustible
depuis 2003 19 églises ont été
complètement rasée par le feu au québec
sans compter celles qui ont été
endommagés mais l'église catholique se
fait rassurante dans la plupart lh2 des
églises auquel je peux penser qu'ils
sont accessibles au public présentement
il ya gîte la système d'alarme-incendie
relier des centrales et puis quand on le
voit assez d'aucun problème les pompiers
son loca québec le gouvernement legault
rappelle que des subventions sont
offertes aux lieux cultes classe et
patrimoniaux jusqu'à 80% des travaux de
restauration du bâtiment classé sont
effrayés par québec et ça inclut
justement la mise
aussi on peut aussi on doit ajouter des
gicleurs par exemple pour l'église
catholique la protection contre les
incendies n'est pas l'enjeu le plus
pressant c'est plutôt celui de
l'entretien général des bâtiments alors
que les fonds sont insuffisants si
olivier bastin radio canada montréal